there are new concerns over e-cigarettes
when it comes to your air travel the
president of the largest flight
attendant Union wants the FAA to ban the
products from all planes that's because
their batteries could be a fire hazard
at least 265 incidents involving
batteries have been reported to the FAA
since 1991 and one of those incidents
happened in January on an American
Airlines flight when an e-cigarette
battery caught fire in a backpack under
a passenger's seat Kris Van Cleave is at
Reagan National Airport that's outside
Washington Chris these batteries are
very common aren't they very much so
Tony I mean they are pretty much in
every mobile device we have so there are
a lot of them on an airplane this is the
backpack that I travel with let me just
show you the number of batteries you got
the laptop of course you have the iPad
you have your wireless earbuds mobile
internet you have your phone so those
are lithium-ion batteries and of course
those portable chargers you use to power
everything now they're concerned about
the e-cigarettes those are often cheaply
made and this may be more prone to
failing spare lithium-ion batteries
sparked this fire in February aboard a
Delta flight while it's sat at the gate
those batteries are in East cigarettes
like this one that went up in flames in
the TSA line at Charleston West
Virginia's Airport and here another fire
at the airport in Savannah Georgia last
year
a quick-thinking TSA officer removed a
smoking bag from security the cause the
battery for a vape pen FAA reports from
1991 through this August show at least
48 East cigarette related smoke or fire
incidents at airports are on planes
that's more than laptops and tablets
cell phones battery chargers or spare
batteries this FAA test video shows why
lithium-ion batteries have been banned
in checked luggage if a battery fails
and enters what's called thermal runaway
it can burn so hot the planes fire
suppression system can't put it out in
2016 the FAA took the unusual step of
banning Samsung Galaxy Note 7
smartphones due to its lithium ion
batteries starting fires lithium ion
we fire on a plane can be catastrophic
Sarah Nelson the president of the
association of flight attendants says
flight attendants have become
firefighters on planes and the FAA needs
to do more how about we just not have
these easy cigarettes on the plane at
all but mark milem from the flight
safety foundation says while batteries
from e-cigarettes are a great concern on
planes more information is still needed
before an outright ban makes sense a ban
could happen when there's the right
information that's understood about it
flight attendants are trained to handle
battery fires that includes putting the
smoldering or flaming device in fire
resistant bags like this one now carried
onboard many planes in a statement the
FAA tells CBS this morning it has clear
regulations on the safe transport of
lithium-ion batteries each cigarettes
vape pens and spare batteries must be
transported in carry-on bags only adding
because of the wide variety of battery
issues that can occur it is important
that airlines have the flexibility to
assess and address the risks involved in
each individual situation the FAA has
done extensive battery testing we should
tell you that just today the inventors
of lithium-ion batteries were honored
with a Nobel Prize for chemistry Gale
that's a nice little button because
Chris your story was not comforting
whatsoever I'm wearing you have a lot of
stuff in your backpack yeah we and a
laptop I do not travel light okay all
right it's always good to see you thank
you sir